[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen sie was
herrschen da mitmachen denkt man hat es
da kommt ein kleines küken raus
allerdings meine lieben freunde ich
merke direkt schon dass ich nicht
richtig laufen kann weil ich auch kein
essen mehr am start aber richtig starker
start in die heutige sohnemann ihm
freunde aber ich würde auch sagen dass
ich euch direkt mal ganz kurz und
heimnetz einblenden ich weiß es relativ
früh in der heutigen episode allerdings
haben wir auch eine menge für heute auf
der to-do-liste ich weiß dass ich das
immer sagen aber heute ist es wirklich
viel und ich muss mich jetzt erstmal
ganz kurz darauf vorbereiten
[Musik]
damit sei ein neuer tag erwartet uns
hier in unserer minecraft welt und
perfekt korrekt auch nicht auf dich ich
werde mich nun auf mein brötchen bewegen
und wieder in richtung ozean monument
fahren das habe ich in der letzten folge
wo wir den unterwasser tunnel gebaut
haben habe ich das ganze ja schon
angekündigt denn ich benötige für etwas
was ich an meiner modernen strand hausen
wieder noch bauen möchte einige see
laternen und die bekomme man nur in der
so viele nüsse gegessen
bereits die ganze zeit diese see
laternen bekommt man nur im ozean
monument und entweder ich brauche sie
laterne an sich ab oder ich töte die
wegfallen außen herum kommen hier vorne
unser brötchen sieht schon schön aus
nachdem ist repariert haben allerdings
befindet sich unser ozean moment ja
dorthin also wir fahren jetzt nicht all
zu lange hatte die hier neu mit dabei
sind ich glaube das dauert jetzt in die
nach halbe minute bis wir da sind von
der quatsch ich mal eben ganz kurz was
ich gerade in der tat alles gemacht habe
ich habe erst mal meine items ein
bisschen sortiert das ganze sieht jetzt
nämlich so aus und da seht ihr auch
schon dass ich mir eine menge getränke
gemacht habe nämlich sechs mal einen
langen trank der unter wasser atmen da
war ein kugelfisch
er wurde sagt die zeit treten muss und
brauche ich brauche nämlich den hier und
hier sind sogar noch zwei weitere
kugelfischer den muss ich aber ganz kurz
töten den benötige ich nämlich ich weiß
dass ich eigentlich keine tiere töten
wollte in diesem projekt parat lebens
benötige ich britische bank denke der
unterwasser atmung und drei stück habe
ich auf jeden fall am trinke ich dachte
die wir noch ein kugelfisch in rom
allerdings reichen drei kugelfisch auf
jeden fall erstmal und ich weiß nicht
wann wir das nächste mal großartig
entlang der unter wasser atmen brauchen
werden allerdings habe ich mir nicht nur
diese sechs tränke unter wasser atmen
gemacht wie ich dann mit einem redstone
im ausstand er verlängert habe auf die
weil sie nicht maximale zeit aber das
doch eigentlich ganz egal denn der
wächter gibt uns ja relativ schnell
wieder dieses abbau leben um
verzauberung sting allerdings habe ich
mir noch sechs milch einmal geholt um
diese abbau lähmung halt direkte weg zu
verzaubern zu können und ich habe mir
auch noch neue nahrungsmittel beschaffen
denn guck mal hier vorne sind schon 16
von den ganzen thunfischen hier und da
unten seht ihr auch schon die laternen
da müssen wir jetzt nämlich hin
da geht es direkt los also mal ganz
schnell hier in milch einmal trinken so
dass ich einfach ganz fix hier keine
abholung mehr habe und jetzt ganz
schnell zu den see laternen hin ich
ignoriere jetzt erst mal die anderen
hier vorne wie die mich attackieren oh
gott das wird nichts das wird nichts
werde mich direkt angreifen ich werde
hier erstmal den schlagen ich kann dir
nicht schlagen
wann kann ich denn geschlagen alter was
soll die scheiße ganz kurze gewitter nur
akzeptiert von allen seiten was soll das
wieso konnte ich den gerade nicht
schlagen kommen von allen seiten kommen
die hier schon wieder an
das war auch wieder klar dass es
wieso war ich dann ist plötzlich wieder
beim brot
was soll denn das warum alter warum hat
er kenne mich schon wieder alle mann ich
habe euch allen nichts getan
ich will einfach nur die laternen bitte
lasst mich in ruhe doch der tapfere held
lucius von und zu löschen burg traut
sich in das boot der monument und tötet
tapfer einen arschloch fallen wächter
nach dem anderen und schaffte sogar
zurück an die oberfläche
freunde ich habe euch ja grad mal so
eine time labs das waren wieder diese
komischen magma blöcke da unten
eingeblendet damit ihr regnet's gerade
erst angefangen zu regnen alter jetzt
wenn es nicht schon düster und spannend
genug wäre kommt jetzt auch noch der
gott und pinkelt auf uns die sache ist
ich habe es tatsächlich geschafft keine
einzige die laterne abzubauen was ich
allerdings geschafft habe jetzt eine
menge prisma in kisten und chris martin
scherben mir zu holen denn die ganzen
wächter arbeitsweise quallen oder kanada
ist die ich getötet habe
die
sind tatsächlich auch lieferanten für
die materialien die ich benötige
umgehende see laterne zu kräften
es ist allerdings deutlich einfacher und
auch deutlich war das jetzt die richtige
richtung die ich hier fahre ich glaube
ja es ist deutlich einfacher wenn ich
diese laternen einfach abbauen
deswegen muss ich mich jetzt noch mal
ganz ganz fix dahin bewegen ich habe
auch noch ganz kurz die abbau leben die
unter wasser atmen von der trinke ich
auch direkt man noch einen rang unter
wasser atmung und jetzt werde ich mich
direkt hier vorne auch mal eben hin
bewegen er sieht auch schon ich hab das
votum der unsterblichkeit in der hand
das heißt wenn ich sterben sollte werde
ich definitiv wieder belebt werden ich
sammle hier vorne auch noch eben schnell
die ins 6 1 und die fische keine ahnung
wo führt das alles braucht hier vorne
liegen sogar auch noch scherben herum
kann ich dann auch noch nehmen um mir
das bis seetang ich idiot ist aber auch
egal meine taktik ist jetzt auf jeden
fall dass ich hier direkt untergehen
werde mit der spitzhacke mit herbert und
mich direkt zu sein allerdings hier hin
bewegen werde so dass ich das hier
hoffentlich direkt abbauen kann ich habe
ablehnung
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich auch ganz kurz
direktmandaten trinken ich muss direkt
runter ich glaube die musste ich alle
ignorieren und hier direkt man diese
laterne mitnehmen sagt ich werde direkt
wieder angegriffen um einen gott alter
das kannst du doch wirklich nicht aus
denkt jetzt muss ich mich wieder auf
meinem boot stellen und hier so ein
bisschen und jetzt erstmal die brote
essen das ist ein bisschen langweilig
gerade deswegen euch einen ganz fixe
time labs noch mal
leute ich hab zwar noch die ablehnung
allerdings bin ich gerade einfach mal
hier rein geschwommen weil ich habe alle
see laternen abgebaut dies gab klar es
gibt hier drinnen noch welche
das heißt ich könnte jetzt mal ganz
kurzen milch einmal trinken mir dann
noch mal eben die unter wasser atmen
rein ballern und mir dann hier noch mal
kurz ein paar see laternen mitnehmen
allerdings reichen eigentlich schon die
die ich habe denn ich habe zu hause ja
auch noch welche plus mit dem chris
martin scherben und kristallen kann ich
mir auch noch welche machen allerdings
habe ich jetzt noch mal acht minuten
unter wasser atmung und kann auch wenn
ich gleich die abholung habe glaube ich
durch einen großen bereich dieser
kompletten ozean monument ruine einfach
durch schwimmen das heißt ich werde die
zeit jetzt nutzen die ich noch habe
nämlich diese siebeneinhalb minuten
gleichwertig auf jeden fall nochmal die
ablehnung bekommen dann kann ich keine
seele mehr mitnehmen ist aber auch nicht
schlimm ich werde dann auf jeden fall
gleichen mich einmal mich auch nicht
mehr das heißt selbst wenn ich den
schwan raum gibt es finden sollte kann
ich auch keine schwemme abbauen
allerdings werde ich auf jeden fall noch
eine menge von den quallen hier töten
von da ihr euch nochmal eine ganz fixe
time labs
ok ich muss hier raus ich habe nur noch
vier herzen und das problem ist auch
dass ich nicht zu essen mehr habe ist
mir gerade mal aufgefallen das heißt
auch wenn ich jetzt ja noch unter wasser
atmen habe für ein paar minuten ein helm
ist auch noch kaputt gegangen in diamant
helm auch wenn ich jetzt noch unter
wasser atmen habe hierfür fünf minuten
hätte ich mich trotzdem nicht ernähren
können klar ich hätte setzen können
allerdings hätte ich davon so viel essen
können von habe ich mir das gesagt
mensch ich gehe jetzt ich habe meine 21
see laternen ich brauche eigentlich nur
zehn stück bitte nicht kaputt war
eigentlich nur zehn stück für meinen
plan mit dem mit der strandvilla hinten
von daher meine lieben freunde ich weiß
ich habe schon eine menge time labs ist
heute gemacht wer aber auch langweilig
gewesen wenn ich dadurch dieses komische
ding einfach durch gesprochen werden
ohne irgendwie eine tanz einzublenden
weil ich ja einfach nur war und die
ganzen qualen getötet habt von einer
noch eine allerletzte times wie ich nach
hause fahren wir die sachen besorge die
wir für das heutige projekt benötigen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt gerade 13 minuten lang
mich hierauf vorbereitet die frage ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich luca wofür brauchst
du vier betten luca wofür brauchst du so
viel beton luca wofür brauchst du noch
mit dem quad blöcke ich dachte wir sind
fertig mit dem quad ja dachte ich auch
die sache ist allerdings dass ich noch
ein weiteres projekt aber neben der
strandvilla und das soll hier hin
das seht ihr schon im titel eingeblendet
zu sehen macht ja keinen sinn dass ich
jetzt die ganze zeit so geheim halten
denn ich möchte einen pool bauen und es
macht eigentlich gar keinen sinn denn
wir haben ja hier außenrum extrem viel
wasser
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht mensch
wenn man hier schon so einem strand hat
dann kann man auch einen pool im wasser
machen
das hat er hier nichts zu tun mit ihnen
die umweltverschmutzung oder
verschwendungen oder verschwenderischen
lebensstil das ist minecraft deswegen
machen wir das einfach worauf er bock
haben und ihr seht auch jetzt gerade
schon mensch luca du baust hier den
glatten sandstein ab ja das hat ganz
einfach damit zu tun dass und der steht
ja auch eigentlich weil hier hinterher
das sieht jetzt sofort ja der kamin ist
ich habe mir gedacht warum denn hier so
eine komische wüsten verwirrung mit
glatten sandstein hin zu machen das
macht er gar keinen sinn
wir machen das einfach mit quad wir
haben ja jetzt wirklich noch eine menge
deswegen hier erstmal den quartz rein
hier und hier die stufe nehmen wir auch
weg und setzten dem durch den quartz wie
gesagt wir denken mit das auge denkt mit
und wenn wir also wenn ich weiß dass
dahinter auch nur und dass sie können
sich zum beispiel auch wegnehmen weil
hinter ist halt nichts das wird nachher
niemand sehen was das ist allerdings
denke ich mir halt immer so ja ich will
dass das perfekt ist klar okay wenn wir
uns das ganze ziel von unten anschauen
dann ist das alles andere als perfekt
aber das kommt wahrscheinlich dann noch
irgendwann so fernen zeit in diesem
projekt nur dafür haben allerdings
dachte ich mir dass wir hier dann
einfach quasi so ein bisschen kurz
hinsetzen können und die wand hier quasi
einmal einen block weiter machen können
[Musik]
das ist kunst auf jeden fall haben wir
jetzt auf jeden fall den kamin ganz gut
versteckt von innen sieht es genau
gleich aus und von außen sieht so
einfach das ist weil ich bekomm ich bin
ja ich bin da wirklich eigentlich kein
fan von allerdings muss ich jetzt machen
und zwar muss ich mir hier vorne hat so
ein paar blöcke einfach krallen und die
ersetzen durch irgendwelche glatten
sandsteinblöcke oder so dass wir das
hier wenigstens vernünftig aber ganz gut
hinkriegen drei blöcke reichen nicht
mehr aus denn ich brauche vier also muss
ich auch noch hier hinten ein entfernen
jetzt mal zwei da vorne eben mit war ja
wieder klar dass mit zwei blöcke fehlen
wie das ist ja wieder so typisch naja
gut auf jeden fall brauche ich mich da
mal ganz kurz die eben noch mal an der
seite hoch entferne jetzt hier vorne die
stufe die im provisorischen gesetzt habe
und zack zack zack dann passt das auf
jeden fall und jetzt kommen wir wirklich
zu dem pool meine lieben freunde
zunächst allerdings möchte ich hier
einige außen liegen hin bauen und zwar
hier hier und hier dann setzen wir davor
einfach birkenholz stufen und dann seht
ihr schon dass wir hier zumindest ein
paar ligen haben und der pool fängt dann
hier vorne an und nun lassen wir hier
von den liegen zwei blöcke frei und
bauen hier vorne den glatten sandstein
ab denn der wird jetzt ersetzt durch
weißen trocken beton beziehungsweise
wenn trockene tonne das wasser berührt
damit der normaler beton so dass das
ganze dann hier so aussieht ich weiß
dass man jetzt mit der mittagssonne
keinen großen unterschied erkennen
zwischen dem glatten sandstein und dem
weißem beton wenn die sonne allerdings
ein bisschen anders steht sieht man das
auf jeden fall plus wenn ich irgendwann
das texture pack mal rausnehmen sollte
oder wenn ich euch die welt zur
verfügung stelle
seht ihr auch direkt dass das wirklich
einen großen unterschied macht zwischen
den beiden blöcken das sieht man auch so
ziemlich toll
allerdings brauchen wir jetzt hier 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 dadurch perfekt
gezählt brauchen wir jetzt die breite
vom pool und nun gehen wir in diese
richtung wieder rüber mit der gleichen
länge wie wir das vorhin auf der seite
da vorne gemacht haben so dass die quasi
hier vorne abschneidet also hier vorne
zack zack zack zack zack zack und dass
ich dann quasi auf dieser seite hier
zusammenkommen mit der seite zeigt das
ist ein bisschen die umrandung vom pool
genau das gleiche machen wir jetzt
nochmal hier drunter so dass wir hier
eine 2 block tiefe wand haben vom pool
und hier packen wir nun den hellblauen
beton reihen der dann so wie es in den
pool boden darstellen sollte dass der
ganze boden hier dann so aussieht und
nun in die ecken immer mit drei blöcken
abstand platzieren wir unsere see
laternen die sache ist allerdings dass
ich das ganze in meiner test welt halt
die eigentlich jedes jede sache die ich
hier in bauen möchte habe ich auch das
in meiner testfeld halt schon
vorbereitet die sache ist allerdings
dass wir jetzt falsch blog dass ich mich
meiner testfeld bisschen verbaut habe
und dachte dass ich nur zehn zähler
tennenbronn und die sache ist nun dass
ich gerade wirklich sehr sehr glücklich
bin dass ich doch ein paar mehr abgebaut
habe hinten im ozean moment denn ich
kann mir gleich einfach entschieden ist
was mit sich immer verwirrter wenn ich
diese mannschaft wie das aufnehmen die
mache immer absolut gar keinen sinn ich
will einmal so rüberkommen herzlich wie
vor dem plan und können zu bauen und
nebenbei auch gute reden aber es geht
einfach nicht da die sonne allerdings
auch schon untergeht und ich noch
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 also noch zwei weitere
serien benötige würde ich sagen ich will
mich erst mal ganz kurz drüber
geschlafen und hole mir diese laternen
und jetzt nehmen wir unsere see laternen
und platzieren die einfach hier in den
ecken das soll so ein bisschen die pool
beleuchtung darstellen und ich weiß
nicht ob das vielleicht ein bisschen zu
viele so laternen sind allerdings denke
ich mir das pulse halt immer so richtig
geil aussehen wenn sie halt nachts
beleuchtet sind von daher guck mal
einfach mal in mitte würde ich jetzt
keine machen die mir mal die kommentare
schreiben ob eventuell noch welche sehen
würdet allerdings konzentrieren wir uns
jetzt erstmal auf einen kleinen
sonnenschirm den ich hier vorne an
gedacht habe und dafür habe ich auch
schon so ein bisschen glaubten sandstein
mitgenommen davon benötigen wir
allerdings glaube ich leider noch ein
bisschen mehr
den möchte ich nämlich hier vorne so
umsetzen so dass es zumindest so
aussieht als wäre hier so ein bisschen
sand drumherum
und zwar möchte ich hiermit ich genau
passend zu diesem see laternen
beleuchtungs ding einen sonnenschirm
setzen einmal kurz hier oben noch einen
drauf jetzt bräuchte ich mir hier ganz
kurz mit dem glatten stellen und
platziere hier eine weiße wolle und
außen rum hier sollen nun betten
hinkommen das heißt ich setze die so das
hat jetzt gerade nicht so sollte es
allerdings funktionieren hier noch ein
bett hin dann nochmal hier kurz drauf
und dann setze ich hier vorne noch ein
bett hin und hier
es mag jetzt vielleicht für den einen
oder anderen ein bisschen suspekt
aussehen und klingen dass ich hier vorne
mit betten meinen schirm darstellen
möchte allerdings sieht es glaube ich
ganz cool aus und es ist zumindest ein
bisschen ein anderer schirm als der den
wir dort hinten haben den sehen wir
allerdings gerade nicht die sache ist
allerdings dass das natürlich nicht
reicht sondern wir brauchen hier
natürlich auch noch sessel drum herum
von na ja dachte ich mir dass wir die so
bauen zack zack zack und auch nicht das
ist falsch der sollte mich ein weiter
nach hinten
und das seit kurzem ein fehler da muss
ich allerdings dann auch noch natürlich
mit dem garten samt ein bisschen
arbeiten damit das ganze hier ein
bisschen an sehen nicht aus wie wir
brauchen davon wirklich noch deutlich
mehr
allerdings sollen diese
keine ahnung was genau darstellen soll
hier hier hier sein wartet derweil als
auch einmal blöd gesetzt ein bisschen
nervös weil ich nicht weiß ich dass
alles nachher aussehen wird und der
andere soll hier vorne sein also hier
hier hier und hier
dann können wir hier vorne mit dem
glatten sandstein so ein bisschen das
alles hier so machen das ist einmal hier
so umgeht bam bam dann haben wir hier
noch so einen kleinen bereich sodass es
nicht komplett abgeschnitten wird mit
den sesseln
dann müssen wir hier als guten übergang
sorgen dass das hier so hinten rüber
geht ich habe allerdings auch auf 64
gestell mit dem staat also sollte das
denke ich alles kein problem darstellen
ich würde sagen dass wir an der stelle
einfach mal so bis hierhin gehen
vielleicht so dass hier alles machen und
dann wollen wir das hier vorne wieder ab
und dann können wir theoretisch ab hier
auch nochmal so ein bisschen glatten
sandstein hier so umziehen so dass es
halt nicht so komplett abgeschnitten ist
hier direkt und dann geht es hier quasi
irgendwie wieder so rüber und dann
verwehrt sich dass hier noch so ein
bisschen vielleicht um die ecke mit
unserem strand und endet dann aber auch
hier vorne und genau das gleiche machen
wir jetzt noch mal hier auf der anderen
seite denn das hier bin ich auch ein
bisschen cooler wenn das hier so ein
bisschen lang laufen würde also
irgendwie so dann hier noch ein bisschen
hier noch ein bisschen sandstein lang
und dann hier irgendwie auch noch damit
sogar noch ein bisschen was übrig das
heißt ich könnte hier noch ein hinsetze
und da dann bei den gerade sandstein
komplett weg wir haben unsere drei
liegen hier gebaut und so sonnenliegen
wo man dann liegen kann perfekt zur
südseite hin die sonne knallt uns die
auf der bräune und dann wenn man mal ein
bisschen shoppen wie kann man sagen dann
setze ich mich hier so ein bisschen hin
dass ich das natürlich sehr gemütlich
aus also das ist wirklich gerade
einpacken allerdings meine lieben
freunde würde ich an der stelle
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
auch beenden wir haben heute wirklich ne
menge geschafft wir waren im ozean
moment haben die see laternen geholt den
schwamm raum haben wir allerdings leider
noch nicht gefunden ich habe jedoch
wieder eine menge wächter getötet und
auch einen weiteren boss wächter habe
ich getötet dann habe ich hier vorne die
wand verdoppelt so dass wir das hier mit
dem kamin nicht mehr auf der einen seite
hier so doof sehen und hier so eine
komische glatte sandstein verwirrung
haben wir haben selbstverständlich den
pool fertiggericht zusammen mit einigen
sonnen sesseln einen sonnenschirm und
drei liegen und wir hatten einfach eine
super coole zeit war um hoch und dem
video hier da abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn die neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt ihr sehen
uns übermorgen im neuen video wieder
[Musik]